I think it's safe to say you are the
idiot you cannot say that it's enhanced
the viewing or maps they experience or
anything of the Premier League this
season
yes it's godless is right which has been
introduced to do what more do you wanted
to do not drinking job take my job very
seriously though you need one after the
result the city grounds at the weekend
don't know by the time this goes out
leads with 10 points clear
[Music]
you know you're wrong come and move it
come on now I'm on euro no because I'll
tell you why now I've got the more
difficult argument here because vyasa's
you're wrong is very unpopular but I
think there are things that have
disappeared from the Premier League or
are disappearing from the privileged age
diving to the extent that it was course
people are still going down under
contact but the blatant dive someone
just going over in the box you know
without any any touch any contact has
pretty much disappeared from the Premier
League because players know they're
gonna get caught managers are talking
more about football after the games down
they have a little moan about bar but it
is nowhere near to the extent of all
this should have been a pennant way you
know that player dived the referee
messed up again yeah I think overall it
has had a positive impact I think yeah
it's ludicrous to say its overall had a
positive impact actually spoke to our
audience a nod to Bible the other day
and only 25 percent of them said it had
a positive impact the whole experience
of watching football has been ruined and
at the end of the day is an
entertainment product and if we hope
being NBA's as watching football has
been ruined that's not a gracious
okay that's maybe a slight exaggeration
but now I support a championship team
the thing I like most about watching
temperature football over Premier League
football is that you know when a goals
gone in you don't have to wait two three
four minutes you don't know if you have
to stop to celebrate you know have this
awful thing in the Premier League racing
fans of both clubs chaning var var
that's not football for me
[Music]
I think I think it's safe to say you are
the idiot we are the village idiot in
this discussion yeah
you cannot say that it's enhanced the
viewing or maps they experience or
anything of the Premier League this
season yes this is right which is what
it's been introduced to do I'm sorry it
hasn't you know entertainment or isn't
giving you a [ __ ] Josh but you know
it's here to get decisions right and
that's why it's done what more do you
want it to do yes it has corrected more
decisions we both agree that's that's a
stat that's a fact you can't disagree
with that but that's what it's there to
do yes but at the same time the whole
experience waiting three four five
[ __ ] minutes doesn't it does happen
all the time
Asian Goodison Park earlier this season
cousin rambles it's to three minutes and
that time is not being added on why
don't we go back to why don't we bother
if we just added the time on would you
be happy no because you're also then
having fans chanting for it you're
waiting three minutes there's a goals
good and then how do you celebrate that
of mine I'm gonna wait five minutes for
then oh let's turn around up we [ __ ]
scored let's celebrate
known as fans when they have a prior
sent off wrongly after 15 minutes we'll
spend the entire game charting about the
referees a wanker yeah yeah quite
exactly so so we've just gone from var
to the referees of wanker yeah football
fans are still mainly about something
the difference is we're getting more
correct decisions and this is a
situation where both of us agree it's
not even being implemented perfectly so
it can still improve from it
[Music]
perfect just where the producers wanted
var isn't turning people off football
that's that's that's just simply not
true
people aren't disappearing from football
they're moaning about it because they'd
love to have something to moan about and
before this was refereeing decisions it
was diving whatever people aren't tuning
off from football in terms of killing
the game I agree they're not turning off
we're addicted to it it's like a drug
it's like that's why I still support
this useless team after 26 years if we
want to continue kind of giving back to
the fans in the center a good
entertaining product and a nice
experience when they're spending
hundreds of pounds to attend matches
across the country we need to make that
experience as close to perfect as
possible and at the moment VA are
staking it way further away from that
which game has been ruined by var this
season lots of games and moments which
you celebrate them I think iconic
Premier League moments you go back to
the agüero imagine that they win the
title but then there's a 3-4 minute
check to see if he was on side if
Balotelli was fouled in the build-up or
any of those sort of things that's not
what football is about I think we both
agree that football's about that
instantaneous moment that's why I love
it the most rugby cricket all these
other sports I watch and I play and I
enjoy but the most impressive thing and
most exciting thing in all of sport is
the moment that ball hits the back of
the net and once you've ruined that
moment that's when it's gone I agree
that football is entertainment as you
say it's about fun but it's also it's
also about trying to find the right
winner as you can in a game or the right
this is you know that that that is the
example I always think is like the 100
meter final ok well there's no kind of
more like visceral more thrilling
instant impact thing in sport but when
two people cross the line at the same
time they go and they have a photo
review it actually takes a couple of
minutes for them to work out and they
don't just go I seen a big final there's
a man on a line he would just like
decide who's won
I see Usain Bolt Justin Gatlin Hirai and
then they look at light when they go on
that was actually that was wrong but but
we don't want to spoil the instant
moment for the fans in the stadium so
let's not worry about now this is know
it to the arena that's quietly 100 me
funnel you want the right person to us
more
five is ten seconds and there's only one
decision that matters one decision and
of course and so what we gonna have a
three hour long football game because
we're gonna check every decision for two
three minutes no one's suggesting that
all that well you're suggesting that we
need to get every decision right let's
suggest in that that you're saying that
it's really important we get everything
right like they do in the hundred meter
final and we don't want to ruin their
everything how many things are we gonna
get right the important things the
basics are fine important like you know
red cards penalties things like that and
yeah we both agree it's not it's not
being used perfectly but that doesn't
mean you just you're just gonna throw it
out all right so the debates over we
both agree that you need to get the most
accurate decision and that video has the
cost of the experience of the game I
agree
I strongly agreed that referees need to
get decisions correctly the problem is
is the quality in the standard of
refereeing isn't abysmal in the Premier
League and even with VL we're still
getting too many decisions that aren't
correct everyone's always complained
about the standard of refereeing
you know I've Constitution this is just
an incredibly difficult job but being a
linesman isn't impossible - I completely
agree it's it for me that's even harder
than me yeah are we having to watch at
the exact time when the Bulls kick -
when someone's a level or not yeah it's
almost impossible how can they do their
job without technology to help them
that's the point where we need to either
look at the rules or the implementation
of the area or both and I think for me
the problem is at the moment is that as
you said there's millimeters offside and
we agree that that is factually offside
the way that they're judging it based on
the TV frames and the meters per second
it's not still accurate it's way more
accurate than a middle aged man or woman
on the sidelines trying to look in two
different points at once which is
impossible I think people just don't
like the offside rule they just don't
like the fact that it's being
implemented correctly right now that's
not to deal with Vaughn
I think that's the easiest thing I've
ever seen in my life one my VR can be
improved if there's if there's doubt you
go with the original on-field decision
so the overall like I umpires calling
exactly exactly the same as an umpire's
calling cricket only it only comes into
play when there's a blatant error and
also I think how do you decide blatant
error I think for me that's part of the
problem is that at the moment there's
two options either there doesn't work or
the rules of football don't work you
could argue both and changing the rules
of football is a very hard thing to do
other sports are better set up for it I
think we mentioned tennis cricket there
they're perfect the VAR or technology
because they are very black and white
calls for football there's so many gray
areas it's really a [ __ ] sport when it
comes to the rules and that's part of
the problem I don't think we can ever
change the rules to accommodate the AR
true and what one side so we just end it
there
do you agree games be ready cut
[Music]
yeah it will be here because the people
who control the game make the wrong
decisions they're so far down the line
with it they won't have the balls to
actually go we [ __ ] up here we need to
go back to what it was they just care
that oh we've got this product we can
sell it for three billion for the next
three years in terms of the TV deal they
don't care that football and the actual
experience of what's going that what it
is to go to a game is being kind of
lessened by var how would you like to
see it implemented in your ideal world
but having var so ideal world there's a
lot of things leads to be won in the
Champions League but in terms of var I
think it's like an autumn var tickets
and I'm not a lot more than five years
but yeah I think for me it's a case of
we need to look at a lot of things why
is it taking so long
we need to either have a time limit
players of teams could maybe have an
amount of challenges like they do in
tennis there are so many sports that are
so much more advanced in the way they're
doing it and we need to trial it maybe
in certain competitions whether that's
the EFL car pool or conversations away
from the Premier League where there's so
much importance and care around it yeah
then we can get to a place we go you
know what it's working a lot better than
it currently is because we both agree
it's in a shambolic place at the moment
I mean I don't agree it's in the
Shambala place by now I just can't say
it right now I do agree that launching
it in the Premier League right off the
bat like this was ludicrous you're right
they should have trialed it in like a
you know competition like the league
carp or like a competition that people
don't really care about other
championship you know one of those
scored out there you could name your
ship you know you should know your
branding yeah but yeah I think like
launching it head-on in the Premier
League was was a mistake
[Music]
despite being pro var I would definitely
go for a drink you seem like a fine good
gentleman who who's knowledgeable about
football yeah by part of the fun of
being a football fan is is talking about
these things it's debating about these
things cheers cheers mate I was always
because I don't do like wrong long term
relationship I know I forgot somebody
else sleeping with someone else yeah but
is literally why that's your honest
answer
[Music]